[Music]
[Music]
kevin let's start off with stable coins
so this has been a
huge
topic of conversation recently we saw
luna that was 60 billion dollars at its
peak
that turned into a failure so what can
we do with the stablecoin ecosystem to
continue to evolve it and ensure
something like this doesn't happen again
yeah it's a great question and very
timely given the last 10 days in this
space um
i i would answer it this way from the
investment perspective
the promise for what a stable coin could
be is is so tremendous and such a huge
opportunity that it's okay to experiment
with different structures and so it's
also all right for one to go to zero
because we're so naicent in this and
we're trying these new ideas and this
was one that didn't work so
maybe going forward using algorithms may
not be as popular as perhaps an asset
based stable coin but i look at it this
way
let's say
i when i do this let's say i'm putting
i'm indexing for europe right now and i
have i'm putting
an index together i'm an indexer so we
service sovereign and and pension plans
and there's many people that do what i
do and let's say you're a sovereign fund
and you're bringing in 250 million u.s
cash a day
because you're an oil magnet or you're
an oil country you want to index that
into the s p x oil x airlines we do that
we get paid for that so we see fund
flows every day
stable coins could be a huge tool for us
think about it this way i want to buy
nestle on the zurich exchange i have to
take us dollars out of new york i have
to send them over to zurich ach three
days there's other ways to wire it but
if you're going to go bank to bank
there's a know your customer basis it
takes time it can be done in 12 hours
but there's a lot of fees involved
then i have to convert it into swiss
francs to trade it i get clipped for two
three four five bips on that no
no value added
if i had a stable coin that both
regulators agreed was a currency and a
payment system
i could do that in two seconds at a
fraction of the cost
buy whatever i want to buy
and then
send it back the same way
that's worth a trillion dollars that's
how big the fx market is in a quarter
just the fees in that now with that
potential
i would love to see some policy either
the hagerty bill which i read the tumi
bill which i read both of those make a
lot of sense to me and get some policy
around this so i could use it as a tool
institutionally yeah absolutely
you know speaking of that you've been
meeting with a lot of political leaders
in north dakota and other areas
and i know there's other rural areas
that have been overlooked for technology
advancement you know as we see the
evolution of the mining opportunity for
the digital asset ecosystem building
this critical infrastructure how can
these rural states leverage this to take
advantage of bringing economic
development and prosperity yeah that's i
mean the mining space is in chaos right
now because of esg concerns i mean
there's no other way to put it the the
market capitalizations of the public
miners which used to be a proxy to the
price of bitcoin a way for institutions
to invest you could buy a basket of
these public miners
that proxy is gone um the stocks have
are down 60 80 percent whatever and they
won't be coming back until we resolve
the csg issue new york is a highlight of
that they're considering you know
canceling a proof of work that would be
a bad outcome for new york that's not a
good idea but it's frozen capital
because new york tennessee valley
montana north dakota
are ideal locations where you could put
mining facilities under full mandate of
hydroelectricity where you wouldn't need
a carbon audit and i think for miners
and data centers that's a huge
opportunity turkey point has just been
recommissioned by biden that's a nuclear
power facility in florida a lot of
interest in that facility for providing
power for data centers it's not just
bitcoin mining we're talking about here
the best outcome for stabilizing a data
center is to lease it to miners during
the period of stabilization and then
convert it to a long-term lease with a
tesla and amazon a
you know microsoft but all of those
giant behemoths including the state
governments want clean
zero carbon esg compliant larry fink
proof
data centers that's what they want yeah
and as we continue to build out this
digital asset infrastructure in the
mining sector
you know there's a lot of people that
think there's the opportunity here where
this becomes a benefit for national
security a better benefit for energy
evolution and creating true renewable
innovation in the space how do you think
that we integrate these energy
opportunities into the everyday business
needs of these utility providers well
assuming
you know proof of work remains
and i think it will i really do
um we have to in every every generation
of chip make them more efficient make
them more energy efficient throw off
less heat for example and that
the the capital available i mean you
think about a facility like uh the one
i'm involved in in norway which is using
excess hydro power so instead of it
going over the dam and never being
returned into the economy we're
capturing it in the form of a data
center that's mining bitcoin right now
we pay tax we support the community
we're building up 300 megawatts there
and we are using power that is not being
used there's many use cases but at the
same time we're trying to find the very
best and most efficient productive way
to mine that coin and the having's
coming so we have to even get better at
it and so that's forcing the industry to
do a much better job on technology but
also figuring out a way to support
communities the stacks in norway heat
hydroponic tomato stacks and a cannery's
been built beside it by the bitcoin
miner there so it's become part of the
community and we're not at war with the
local government because we're part of
the local government they're they're you
know shareholder in it and i think
that's the new way to build these data
centers and these mining facilities is
figuring out you know jurisdictions that
are pro
energy
and you know if it's nuclear power or if
it's
or if it's hydro it's great
united arab emirates building a massive
data center around a nuclear power plant
upstate uh quebec
used to be upstate new york no longer
that's that's their problem but it's a
shame that they're not taking advantage
of what they have
yeah that's a great point now i want to
shift gears a little bit now and kind of
move over to regulation so i've heard
you talk a lot about
the opportunity to create thoughtful
regulation in the digital asset space
and i would love to learn from your
perspective
how can the united states become a
leader in blockchain
well
a lot of people
don't want regulation but let me make
the base case for why
everybody in this room wants it
let's just take the granddaddy asset
bitcoin okay let's just start there
you may be excited that it's at 800
billion market cap
that is absolutely
a nothing burger in the context of
financial services it is a rounding
error because the majority of wealth in
the world is managed by sovereign wealth
and pension plans both stateside and
around the world
100 billion 200 billion one trillion
dollar mandates that do not own a single
bitcoin not one so for all the
excitement that we have in these
conferences and this is very important
to discuss
it is so nascent it is not even on the
radar of these asset allocators and
they're not going to put it on the radar
until it gets cleared by the sec in one
way or another because the majority of
their wealth is indexed into the s p the
largest market on earth and if you don't
have access to that because you're
somehow rogue
it's not worth buying bitcoin it's not
worth buying bitcoin at all because it's
a tiny fraction of what they're trying
to manage now if we could get regulation
and i would argue if we could just
regulate one coin at the beginning let
it be bitcoin and one stable coin that
would be fantastic but staying on
bitcoin here's what would happen
i'm an indexer i asked the sovereign
wealth what allocation would you put
into bitcoin and the typical mandate for
those guys we have 11 sectors of the s p
their their rules are long only no more
than 20 in any one sector no more than 5
in any one stock so they may initiate
their index of bitcoin at 50 basis
points
when you're running a trillion dollar
mandate that is a ton of money and so
all of a sudden the demand for that
asset bitcoin becomes higher the price
goes up but it gets better
if they bought it at let's say thirty
thousand dollars and it's and their
mandate is they're going to be a fifty
percent or let's say one percent waiting
and it goes to a two percent waiting
within 90 days they sell it back down to
one percent or if it drops
they buy it back up they are the eternal
bid for the asset and all of a sudden
the stability of bitcoin instead of
having 50 swings every 12 months or more
that's that's gone forever because
there's an underlying multi-trillion
dollar bid for the asset now
i don't know why there's a single person
in this room that wouldn't want that
so i encourage limits and i encourage
hagerty and i encourage toomey all of
these regulators let's get going here
because the rest of the world is far
advanced canadians already have an etf
in bitcoin they already have an ethereum
etf the swiss have already licensed a
dealer broker attached to a crypto
exchange so is canada the uae is doing
the same thing with the adgm i run
around the world trying to find places
to put money to work it's everywhere
else except the united states what's
wrong with this picture
it's broken we got to fix it we and i
know there's a lot of other political
agenda on before the midterms but and
i'm sure biden isn't sitting there
saying i wonder what kevin o'leary
thinks about regulation on bitcoin i
mean he doesn't care because he's got a
lot of other issues but we got to get
this dealt with on the other side of the
midterms i agree and i think as we
continue to get these regulations dealt
with we're going to see huge
institutional inflows of capital and
we're already seeing that today there's
more institutional adoption and interest
than ever before in the crypto space and
you've even noted before that you think
the crypto will be the 12th sector of
the s p why do you think that because of
the productivity you think about the
number one sector of all sectors the
grandmother grandfather its currency and
its financial services no economy can
operate without it the productivity
enhancement tools that are available now
as you contemplate higher speed
transactions what polygon is doing
aggregating on top of ethereum figuring
out all these things all these
incredible teams and i look at it you
know i've said this countless times but
it's so apropos right now bitcoin is not
a coin it's software ethereum is
software solana software helium is
software poll in his software these are
all software projects the amount of
you know intellectual capital going into
these projects these are the smartest
coders in the world they don't want to
go work in in in any of the
other 11 sectors right now you graduate
from waterloo you graduate from mit you
come out of temple and you're a coder
you're going one way to blockchain
that's where you want to be now when you
get that much intellectual capital
working on something and i'm an investor
i got to wet my beak are you kidding i
know there's going to be incredible
outcomes i just don't know which ones so
i've spread across 32 positions right
now i'm sure the majority
won't work but i only need a few
i mean i own these things that they're
nascent you know beginnings and i'm
hoping that some of these ideas work out
and we haven't even touched on nfts yet
i mean there's so much going on here
that you've got to spread your bets you
can't just be a big chunk of bitcoin a
big big chunk of ethereum you know that
you've done it very successfully you've
got the best performance record of any
hedge fund i mean
that's good work i appreciate that it's
so funny though because it's the
traditional warren buffett strategy that
has allowed us to you know perform well
not opportunistic too
absolutely i get it um so in this line
of thinking with investment you know you
used to be very against crypto and then
there was a turning point where
i think you really had this light bulb
moment where you're like okay this is
happening and there's nothing stopping
it why is this such an amazing
investment opportunity today
my turning point and i i get that that
pomp video shoved in my you know what
every day
from the uh from the cnbc interview
every day he never lets me forget but
the turning point for me was getting a
call from one of the
analysts i work with that watches the
osc in canada where we have a lot of
investments
saying they're going to license the
world's first
crypto exchange attacks attached to a
dealer broker
and that just said whoa
i mean that that's that's a game changer
a lot of people don't understand what
that means but what it means is that
every canadian citizen in every province
can open an account transfer fiat
currency canadian dollars into it and be
completely 100 compliant
on their own crypto exchange and they
granted that in an order from the osc
that
changed everything for me i said okay
what's going to happen next and within
weeks the very first etf was launched on
the toronto stock exchange then the
ethereum etf raised five billion dollars
in something like 48 trading hours so
that's the beginning and then i saw the
swiss then i saw what happened in london
then the adgm in in uae
it's all happening moving forward and
nothing's happening here it's a very
strange eerie situation that the u.s
wouldn't lead on policy and now i think
with these senators you've seen here
today and other policy makers coming
they get the joke
and i think as an industry we've got to
feed them as much information as we can
to get it right
because a lot of this code there's
something very wrong when the brightest
minds out of mit or samford are living
on a caribbean island
what is that
like what does that tell you
that tells you that we don't have the
infrastructure here on policy to bring
these geniuses back on our soil and all
the jobs and wealth they're creating
that's just wrong it's 100 wrong and we
got to fix it if you like that video
wait did you see my next one don't
forget to click right over here and
subscribe